president biden in new york city today
trying to show fearful americans that he
is ready to get tough on crime the
president meeting with mayor eric adams
while cities across the country see a
surge in violence but instead of going
after the liberal policies being blamed
for this bike the president was very
much laser focused on guns
we want to crack down on the flow of
firearms used to commit violence that
includes taking on and shutting down
rogue gun dealers
at uh as it's about doing background
checks this doesn't violate anybody's
second amendment right
there's no violation of a second
amendment right we talk like there's no
amendment it's absolute when the
amendment was passed it didn't say
anybody can own a gun and any kind of
gun and any kind of weapon
you couldn't buy a cannon
and with democrats facing backlash for
defunding the police president biden is
trying to reset that message
the answer is not to abandon our streets
that's not the answer we're not about
defunding we're about funding and
providing the additional services you
need beyond someone with a gun strapped
to their shoulder i don't hear many
communities no matter what their color
their background stand i don't want more
protection in my community
i don't know i haven't found one of
those yet so greg a lot of build up to
today's visit what did you think oh he's
terrible and i hate i i i don't like to
get over hyperbolic but he really is bad
and really even on something as as
prepared as that it's embarrassing to
watch on nearly every metric regarding
law and order the dems have screwed the
pooch it's no wonder the white house dog
is so miserable it's infuriating though
you see the democrats swoop down to
solve a catastrophe that they themselves
created what they're resetting is the
thing that they they destroyed because
they picked the wrong side they obeyed
the woke they abandoned society and
victims of crime and now
it took this display the visual display
of suffering
of to get them to worry because they
only they needed they needed an op an
optic they needed something oh this
could hurt me and it shows you what the
woke obsession replaced the wok is said
oh we're helping replace racism in
society no you replace the spinal
fortitude of the democratic party that's
what's missing they lost the balls to go
after criminals right they can't
criminalize crime they now look at
victims as actual like well everybody's
a victim now you're a victim of society
it's really depressing when you see he
didn't talk about the revolving door no
no cash bail the reduced sentencing uh
uh these are or the policies that those
widows succinctly described and
condemned didn't even talk about gangs
instead they go after gun manufacturers
as opposed to gunmen the people getting
pushed in front of the subways were not
shot the people getting stabbed were not
shot so the conclusion is only
republicans can do this because they're
the only people who understand
incentives and disincentives and they're
not afraid of criminalizing crime
democrats
they're done emasculated castrated they
allowed the woke to strip them of any
kind of spine it's over for them they
have to get the hell out of dealing with
criminals okay judge you wanted us to
play one thing because he's talking
about biden can we just play this and
get your full commentary because this is
joe biden in 1993
they must be taken off the street for
simple pragmatic reasons if we don't
they will or a portion of them will
become the predators 15 years from now
very different okay very different so
for those of you who think that he
doesn't know how to handle crime he
knows how to handle crime who knew how
to handle at 93. his language wasn't so
great but he knew what he had to do
greg this is not a resetting this is a
guy who came in for a photo op this was
not a reset he's talking about bankrupt
background checks are you kidding me if
i buy a gun in harlem you think that i'm
going to say hey wait a minute i want to
do a background check he's also talking
about the fact that he doesn't know of
one community that doesn't want more
protection hey congress doesn't want
more protection the squad doesn't want
more protection most of the democrats
don't want more protection and the other
thing is he didn't address the problem
the problem in new york is very simple
number one there is
criminal privilege they don't get
arrested if they do they get released
they don't get prosecuted if the
president were serious number one he
would have said i'm going to meet with
the governor about discussing whether or
not the da's are enforcing the law we
don't need any new laws we've got the
laws number two i want to talk with the
head of the legislatures to make sure
that they at least give judges
discretion to hold violent offenders now
number three he says we've got the
federal prosecutors who are going to
help us with gun prosecutions that's
hogwash in the whole united states in
2020 do you know how many federal gun
crimes were prosecuted allegedly in 50
states 12 000 that's like 200 estate
i mean those numbers are an
embarrassment they don't know how to do
it this is all nonsense talk it's got
nothing to do with changing anything and
it won't geraldo well i think that uh
first of all i agree with a lot of what
greg said the where i differ is
the
bending over backwards it seems to me to
protect the second amendment where it
becomes so obvious
that it seems agenda driven
guns are what is different from when i
was your age when i was uh you know a
street reporter uh
in those days there was plenty of
knifing plenty of violence there was
crack there was everything and i think
you're gonna do crack uh on your show
tonight right you are uh
everybody's got a gun now and
everybody's using a gun now that is
what's different so i i went full stop
that's the point i want to make on that
the other thing is i thought that biden
going and standing with mayor adams was
a good thing i mean it was a i
appreciated that he came the city feels
very troubled for someone born and
raised here and and who adores the city
i feel that there's a real vibe a scared
vibe that i i don't like and i i
appreciate
that the president came and spoke to the
mayor and i really believe that this
mayor is the guy i think that this guy
is he understands that moore and rivera
and their passing was a very monumental
uh an epic event uh you know the fact
that there was two hispanic cops and uh
sumit sulan the 27 year old i think
south asian i'm not sure what his
background is i mean it's a different
police force it's reflecting the ethnic
makeup of the city we get it now i want
to bring back stop and frisk i want to
talk to bill bratton and the old guys
ray kelly uh you know how can we make
this better make people feel better
about it uh but i i do believe that guns
are what is different
there were more shootings and homicides
in the 80s during the crack epidemic
than there are now that there's more gun
ownership now so i'm not sure that makes
any sense geraldo
joe biden said he was a friend of law
enforcement his whole career right we're
supposed to believe that he walks into
this meeting today room packed full of
law enforcement
no one barely even clapped they clapped
louder for barack obama and could you
imagine if trump walked into a room like
that this place would be on their feet
they know
he's not their friend so he gets up
there doesn't say a damn thing about the
d.a doesn't say anything about the dumb
bail laws it would be like some football
team greg i know it's a football analogy
try to follow along losing 28 to three
the head coach goes into the locker room
after the game and just starts chewing
out
the offense and saying you know you guys
only scored three points you guys got to
put in the ends with me well defense
gave up four touchdowns this is a team
effort you can't have the police doing
one thing and the da's not doing the
other thing it's all got to work
together and he doesn't understand that
right now he was a typical politician he
comes in and he takes the easy way out
right he didn't want to talk about the
left and for a guy that loves root
causes never said anything as you said
about gangs about the culture of
violence about narcotics trafficking he
just left it alone so here's my advice
to the president
pretend like you're a one-term president
because you are
you're term limited have that mentality
right forget about the donors forget
about the squad do what you think is
right to protect the people and i think
the people will reward you for that hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else